[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who
always expects the expected and it's
time to ragnarok and roll as episode 2
of loki is now out worldwide
as always we're going to be breaking
down the entire episode's plot
pointing out all the devil in the
details including some big easter eggs
and things that you might have missed
we'll also be giving our review of the
series so far and how it stacks up next
to one division and falcon in the winter
soldier so make sure you stick around
until the end game
now first up i think we have to address
the big reveal in the episode which is
that the loki varian is actually lady
loki
played by sofia dimartino when the show
was filming
this was leaked and we can now pretty
much confirm that the person
everyone thought was black widow in the
trailers is actually her
when we first meet her one of her horns
is cut in half and this is a reference
to agent of asgard
in which the character had something
similar on his crown i actually got
access to the first two episodes of the
show
so i didn't want to spoil it in my last
breakdown but i was really surprised at
how many people who also got the same
privileges
just out and out said that it was her to
pass it off as a theory
i even watched one where they said it
could be her and then started using
she pronouns for the rest of the video
what the bloody hell
is wrong with you we're never getting
early access again
nope all that for a drop of clout
now from this point onwards i'm going in
as blind as you guys
and daredevil and this episode has a lot
to theorize about it
now we open in oshkosh wisconsin in the
year 1985
at a renaissance fair 1985 is the year
that back to the future was set
and similar to that film we get an
adventure that involves our heroes
traveling to the past and future
i love how they have this idea here that
people are dressing up like the past
in an attempt to relive it the tva are
literally able to do this
and can appear at any point in time and
there's some really cool easter eggs
at this location now firstly we see the
dragonfly armory
which could be another dragonfly an
armored character from the marvel
universe
next we get what i think is a cameo of
agatha hawkness
before the big reveal in one division
that it was agatha
all along we noticed that agnes never
really flinched when wonder before magic
in front of her
and this was because stuff like that
didn't surprise the character
the tva step out of a temporal doorway
in front of her here
but rather than being shocked at that
she's annoyed they aren't wearing
traditional medieval attire
agatha is however and it looks similar
this style to what she wore in salem
agatha of course was alive during the
period that this festival is celebrating
so i think it's hilarious that she's
gone to one just to feel more at home
now the actress is kate berlant and not
catherine han but if people can go wild
over peggy carter then we can go bloody
wild over this
clickbait clickbait clickbait agatha is
of course a big bad villainess in the
mcu
and it's not too long before we come
across another one in a tent
this is lady loki who uses her mind
control powers to turn
c20 played by sasha lane against the
other minutemen
she kicks the crap out of them to i need
a hero by bonnie tyler
which sort of sets up how the tva need a
hero in order to take on lady loki
thus they have turned to a variant of
her in loki
who will no doubt go from villain to
hero as we progress through the show
she steals one of the tba's time doorway
devices and on this we can see that
there's a directory
settings panel time door and an icon of
miss minutes
no idea what that last one does but
speaking of her i forgot to mention last
week that she's actually voiced by tara
strong
who you might know as being someone that
provided the original voice of harley
quinn
and she's responsible for pretty much
creating her signature sound
in thor and loki double trouble issue 3
lady loki actually gained a device that
allowed her to jump across dimensions
and i feel like this is very much
pulling from that comic
lady loki takes c20 and we cut to the
title screen which is in black and white
just like the last time the letters
constantly shift as a nod to the
different versions of loki
an armor fisto obsession last week
blinded us from the fact
that one has devil horns which are
supposed to represent his helmet
cut to loki reading a jet ski magazine
and he's being quizzed by miss minutes
on what happens when a nexus event
breaches a red line
this is a very important line of
dialogue as we learn that it means the
tva can't reset the timeline
and a branch is created this leads to
the destruction of the timeline
and the fall of reality as we know it
but let's be honest here
we've lived through 2020 love i think we
can handle a little destruction of
reality
episode 1 was full of old tech and on
the desk we can see an
old league siegler which are now no
longer produced
the miss minutes hologram responds to
loki even though it's a recording
and this is likely because she's already
aware of the conversation
due to her knowledge of time if you've
ever seen the doctor who episode blink
then you'll know that someone was able
to have a conversation with a doc on a
tv with footage that was recorded
decades before
because he already knew their responses
due to them making notes on the
conversation that they had whilst
talking to the recording
this was then given to the doc and it's
a lot of timey why me wibbly wobbly
stuff
but i feel that miss minutes is sort of
doing the same thing
don't know if that made sense or if i
explained it well which i probably
didn't but moving on now mobius says
there's been an attack and he gives him
a tva jacket with varian printed on the
back
turns out mobius's desk is just along
from casey
who he threatened to gut like a fish
which i forgot to point out was it not
to scream
now the jet ski has a lot of meaning as
it's clear that mobius wants to ride one
off into the sunset
he very much reminisces on the 1990s to
loki at the end of the episode
and it turns out that he's never ridden
one now mobius has such a strong
impression of the 90s
and this could be a nod to the character
actually debuting in 1991
mobius says he can't go off and do it
because it would create a branch
timeline
but i do feel the season will end with
him riding one off into the sun
all the tva members are pretty much
slaves and whether they're reduced to
just being a number
or not even knowing what a fish is it's
clear that they're indoctrinated into
believing that they have a purpose
and really there's no reason for them to
want to be alive
now the rivalry between b15 and loki
heats up a bit
and he calls him a cosmic mistake when
you think about it he pretty much isn't
even the main variant that we followed
through the mcu
as that one is now on his way to asgard
to be locked up
interestingly the hologram we see of our
loki has blue skin
and this is because he is of course a
frost giant
last week the picture of mephista sorry
the devil had a blue tongue
and the child too had won because of the
kablooey turns out there's several
variants walking around
and this includes a tour de france
winner wearing yellow
just like the most recent one however
instead of the united arab emirates logo
on his chest
he just has loki we have a hulk loki
one that looks a lot like the mandarin
and a viking one
loki of course himself is a viking god
so this
is a nice little nod to that loki also
explains his powers
and we learn that the variants have
different abilities which is how lady
loki is able to control
others and shift this possession from
person to person
they ship out to the renaissance fair
and loki asks why they didn't just head
back towards the attack
turns out nexus events destabilize the
time flow and they don't want to create
even more branches
so they have to show up in real time
loki warns them that they're in great
danger
and says they're underestimating this
loki variant
hilariously he calls them the lesser
loki throughout the episode
and she sort of does get the drop on him
showing that
he underestimated her too he talks about
the legends of wolves in asgardian
history
and in thor ragnarok we of course came
face to face with one in the form of
fenris
who is a giant wolf from nordic culture
loki calls the asgardians gullible
and we know this is true as he was able
to masquerade as odin for several years
without being noticed
logie pretty much spoils the entire
episode early and says that lady loki
wants them to follow c20
so that she can spring her trap and get
loki so that they can both take down the
tv8 together
this is sort of what happens in the
entry but instead it's loki who tries to
recruit her to overthrow the tva
and he very much was just playing his
hand here who knows he might have just
revealed the entire plot of the season
and it's going to be really interesting
to see if this all comes to fruition
spoiler alert for that entire bit and if
you're enjoying the video then i'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up
as we're going to be breaking down the
show like this each and every week
i've also just started up a new tick
tock page so
hello fellow kids and it's got some of
our best easter eggs on that that'll be
linked in the description below
now loki sarcastically says he now
worships the sacred timeline
and that he can deliver the variant but
that he needs assurances
he won't be wiped out when the job's
over he states he needs to speak with
the timekeepers
as they're in grave danger but mobius
figures out he's lying
because hey he's loki weirdly though he
was telling the truth
and because of this they might even
overthrow the entire tva
in order to rule over them the branch is
pruned
and you might remember from episode 1
that this terminology
could be seen on a poster cut to ravana
and slayer's office
and we see the statue of the timekeepers
as well as several artifacts
weirdly she's recording the entire
meeting and though this
might be for herself i actually think
it's either for the timekeepers
or the one controlling them mobius says
that he's never seen them before
and the way that ravana talks about them
it sounds like they're one person
instead of three same bloody pronouns i
tell you
spoiled lady loki and now they're
spoiling this
now google map raw has discussed the
show quite recently
and she said there's a lot of secrets
involving her character
so we shouldn't be taking everything
that we see here at face value
since episode 1 it's been scratching
away at me that kang
is behind it all and this isn't like
some mephisto [ __ ]
as we know the character has already
been cast and is being played by
jonathan mages
to me you don't do the tva without the
villain in it
and if the timekeepers are all powerful
and surely
variants shouldn't be created in the
first place i think that kang is
manipulating events and that he has
allowed loki to come into the tva to
tear it apart
thus creating the multiverse ren slayer
has long been linked with him
and it just makes a lot of sense to me
nomobia says he's sort of playing with
his loki
who is stalling for time but in doing
this it's allowing him to better
understand the one out there in the
world
but i think he's actually got a bit of a
soft spot for him now this is the newest
bromance since
falcon and the baron zemo and though he
says he's a scared little ice run
shivering in the cold he's also a
lovable [ __ ]
like another lad around here now mobius
signs an event report with a pen
that we see has the words franklin d
roosevelt high school on it
historically this was one of the first
schools in dallas built for black
students
and it was a key location that helped to
educate black people
in a time when many didn't want them to
have the same rights as white people
we can also see an hourglass symbol
etched into red slayer's door
and loki tries to work the situation to
make it so it's
actually a lesson in understanding him
expect the expected when dealing with
loki
and into ragnarok thor finally managed
to outsmart him
by knowing that he would always try and
betray him loki is told it's his last
chance
and we cut to the trippy infinity
elevator with the timekeeper statues in
front of it
this is actually a real world location
and it's the inside of the marriott
marquis in atlanta
loki goes to floor 372 and it's clearly
a nod to the fact that the tva
themselves debuted in issue 372 of thor
we can also catch lk3 which was shown as
a floor on the elevator panel
from episode 1. we see several of these
throughout the episode
making me wonder where the mysterious x
and miss minutes floor leads to
and all this anticipation is giving me a
raging hard boner
fan theory idea now loki rings an old
hotel bell
further showing repurposed items from
our world and we later see casey
drinking some boku juice
this has now been discontinued and no
longer exists
in this episode mobius also drinks a can
of josta energy drink
which too is no longer produced so i'm
expecting to see some more products like
this popping up
loki requests all the files from the
beginning of time until the end
but they're classified and the only one
he's granted is about his life
furthermore we see his surname lauper
son again and this is because he's the
son of laufey
and not odin hiddleston shows off his
acting chops once more
as he reads over the destruction of
asgard at the hands of certain
and we see that there were 9719 deaths
caused
it's heartbreaking for him knowing that
he and his people are doomed
but he realizes that disasters at leader
mass deaths
are the key to finding where lady loki
is if one were to travel back in time to
say
hiroshima before it was bombed you could
pretty much do what you wanted without
worrying about the butterfly effect
as the entire area would be destroyed
and thus nothing in the timeline would
ever change
because of this a nexus event wouldn't
occur and thus the tva
would be completely unaware loki
demonstrates this with mobius lunch
by throwing salt in it and some boku
juice
and overall it's better than my wife's
cooking you're having that
now weirdly he talks about pushing hulk
off the bridge and how it wouldn't have
changed anything
but then if that had happened fenris
would have killed heimdall
which would have had a knock-on effect i
know that most of the asgardians were
killed by thanos shortly after but
i'm not sure that this example quite
works and mobius is cautious because he
thinks loki will stab him in the back
and one time when he and thor were
children there was a part where he
transformed into a snake because
yeah he knows thor loves snakes and he
said
it's me and stabbed him
now loki denies stabbing anyone in the
back and he convinces mobius by saying
he loves to be right
they travel to 79 a.d namely pompeii in
italy
man vesuvius famously erupted there and
killed the majority of the population
even freezing some of them forever in
stone by the ash that formed and dried
on them
there were even people who were
petrified in their beds as they slept
and i definitely recommend that you
check it out if you ever go to italy
now the vfx team couldn't use footage of
pompeii because
cameras didn't exist allegedly and thus
they used the eruption from the 1980s
saint helens volcano
as a reference on how it would act loki
frees some goats
and says be free my horned friends and
his helmet is of course meant to look
like the horns of a goat
and also the devil
[Music]
now loki is proven to be right and
mobius correctly deduces that they have
to be naturally occurring with no
survivors
after realizing that kablooey was only
produced between certain years
and that it was available at a certain
location they track lady loki to the
rocks caught disaster
we learned that she's laying low at the
rocks court store and
due to the double x in its name this is
likely playing on the corporation
roxanne from the comics the head of
roxon dario agar ended up taking loki's
father's skull at one point
and he even built a church in the name
of the character now though not fully
introduced into the mcu
they did appear on the side of a tanker
in iron man 3 and are likely popping up
at some point in the future
judah marvel pretty much running out of
characters and companies that they
haven't put into the mcu this fall
the team traveled to 2050 and we see as
a tsunami in hurricane
closing on the area i absolutely love
the music here
and it really ramps up this finale to be
the height of the season so far
loki dries his clothes using magic but
he's likely still
wet and just changing his outer
appearance in thor the dark world he did
something similar when he was in a cell
and he projected the idea that he was
okay when he looked worse than i did
during the middle of lockdown now b15
and loki go together
and come across someone suspiciously
shopping for plants
in the middle of a hurricane we see that
lady loki is capable of passing on her
possession by touch
and it sort of draws out the mystery of
who exactly she is
now you might have seen last week that
there were several reports about how
loki as a character is gender fluid
and with logie being a nose tricks to
god this very much ties into how we can
often fool people
in the comics after the events of
ragnarok loki was reborn into the body
of lady loki
and potentially this could be what
happened to the character after the
events of infinity war
which of course took place almost
immediately after the third thor film
now in the source material they make it
very very clear that she is just a
continuation of the original loki
however they've left it a bit ambiguous
here she does say things like if
anyone's anyone you're me
and smiles like him but it could be a
reach and it certainly won't be the last
one in this video so
something to look forward to for you
guys now the tva finds c20
and lady loki jumps across from body to
body before revealing herself
loki says he now knows why thor found
him so annoying
and asks if she wants to join him in
overthrowing the tva
in order to rule them we see that lady
loki has set up several reset charges
around the entire building
and we learn that c20 has given away how
to find them
the episode ends with lady loki setting
the charges to explode
and these all drop through doorways to
what i'm guessing are timelines that the
tva are located at
i love how the score takes on the theme
of a ticking clock here as it speeds up
towards
what is the apocalypse as she steps
forward you might also notice that some
of the tvs have the same zero signal
display
that was used during the credits of one
division the lady loki has a crown of
thorns
much like the one in the mephisto
stained glass window and the pair flee
together to who knows where
several branches in the timeline are
created that are too much for the tva to
handle
and this bombing of the sacred timeline
makes ravona rent slayer grab her own
stun stick to go out and fight now as
for where they're going
i think that we may have already seen
this in one of the trailers
in the one where it looks like loki is
speaking to black widow he's likely just
sat with her and i think the pair will
be discussing her life
origins and what came to be this is
clearly at an apocalypse event
that looks like what happened when the
moon exploded and potentially
this might even be titan thanos of
course threw a moon in
infinity war and the purple glow does
look similar
to what comes from the power stone
however when we see the reset charges
being sent to the sacred timeline
on the screen there is a listing for
several locations including voromir
asgore sikor ego heller and more
these are of course key locations in the
mcu another one on voromir happens in
2301
it's clearly a very important event that
could have massive ramifications
so though black widow did die in 2014
maybe she could be popping up again in
the next episode but
we don't really know now interestingly
the one for asgard goes to 2004
which is just before the events of thor
and this could link into the king loki
moment that we saw in the trailer
for sakhar it's 1984 which might end up
killing the grand master
so that the loki events in ragnarok
happened differently
and titan was also bombed in 1982 but no
idea what that's about as the planet was
likely destroyed at that point
now i kind of feel that lady loki may
have come from the timeline in which it
looked like the nuke struck during the
battle of new york
and this wiped out the entire city this
would send her off on a massively
different tangent to what happened in
the mcu
as all the avengers but maybe bruce
banner would have been killed
i think next time we will be discovering
more of the ins and outs of where she
came from
and the next episode might even end with
the cliffhanger of vote loki
with him saying what did you expect as
that just seems like
you know something that you would end an
episode on going from there i think that
the pair might jump about from timeline
to timeline
in order to build an army of loki's to
carry out their plans
there's so much going on in this episode
i think him stepping through the doorway
leaving mobius in the dust
was a brilliant brilliant way to close
things out now as for my thoughts on the
episode i think this was probably a lot
better than the first one
which felt a bit too heavy on the
exposition and
introductions i'm someone who normally
prefers things once the ball gets
rolling
and it's rare that i actually like an
origin story because they just sort of
follow the same story beats
last episode was very much the bad guy
goes in there could be good within him
he unlocks it and learns something new
about himself
that's normally a stereotypical origin
story so to have this just hit the
ground running
was a lot better for me there's a real
sense of urgency to it
and actually being on locations through
our time i think is much better than
just sitting in the offices like we did
in the last episode
proper slagging the show off here but
last time i did compare the pilots of
one division
falcon and the winter soldier and loki
to say what i felt was the strongest
opening
for me falcon had the best first episode
but if we're now comparing the first two
then i think loki
far outclasses the others as the two
fell pretty flat for me on both shows
tom hiddleston is absolutely nailing the
role and i'm really surprised at how
much i like owen wilson as his buddy
i'm not saying wilton is a bad actor or
anything he's always been fun and
light-hearted
i just really wasn't expecting to like
him this much you also have the arrival
of the first big variant
and though i think we know what's coming
down the line in terms of the others
there's still so much to enjoy great
episode
better than the first for me and yeah
very excited to see what's coming around
the corner
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts and theories so make sure you
comment below and let me know
i said thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into our
prize draw on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the phase three mcu box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
they're messaging me on twitter
heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the tva
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over mobius and mobius the
timekeepers
kang the conqueror and everything you
need to know about the organization
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more but out of the way
thank you for saying through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next
time take care peace